bienvenido de nuevo a "Entendiendo la información y computación cuántica", mi nombre es John Watrous y soy el director técnico
de educación en IBM Quantum, esta es la n-ésima lección de la serie y es la última lección de la
segunda unidad de la serie, que trata sobre algoritmos cuánticos; hemos hablado del modelo de consulta de computación, incluyendo algoritmos cuánticos
que ofrecen ventajas demostrables sobre los algoritmos clásicos dentro de ese modelo; hemos discutido conceptos fundamentales relacionados con
los algoritmos cuánticos y cómo podemos medir el costo computacional, y en la lección anterior discutimos la estimación de fase y el algoritmo de Shor
en esta lección hablaremos sobre el algoritmo de Grover, que ofrece una ventaja cuadrática de lo cuántico sobre lo
clásico para los llamados problemas de búsqueda no estructurada, que describiré una vez que entremos en la
lección; todos estos son temas fundamentales sobre los algoritmos cuánticos; hay otros algoritmos cuánticos
así como paradigmas generales que unen diferentes algoritmos cuánticos y técnicas algorítmicas cuánticas, y
si te interesa, te animo a que consultes el "Quantum Algorithm Zoo", que categoriza los algoritmos cuánticos conocidos e incluye muchas referencias
a artículos de investigación originales que han contribuido a su desarrollo; para esta serie, sin embargo,
vamos a quedarnos solo con los fundamentos y, a partir de la próxima lección, pasaremos a un nuevo tema, pero
primero hablemos sobre el algoritmo de Grover; aquí está la descripción general de la lección: comenzaremos con una breve discusión sobre
el problema computacional que abordaremos, que es la búsqueda no estructurada; intuitivamente,
puedes pensar en el problema de búsqueda no estructurada como buscar en una colección de elementos que no está ordenada ni ha sido organizada de una manera útil
luego hablaremos sobre el algoritmo de Grover, que es un algoritmo cuántico que ofrece una ventaja cuadrática sobre los
algoritmos clásicos, y veremos con precisión qué significa eso en breve; una descripción muy general de
cómo funciona este algoritmo es que primero hay un paso de inicialización y luego una operación a la que me referiré como la
operación de Grover, que se itera cierto número de veces, y finalmente se realiza una medición que revela un candidato
a solución del problema de búsqueda; explicaré qué es la operación de Grover y cómo puede
implementarse en una computadora cuántica, y luego haremos un análisis de esta operación para entender mejor qué hace y por qué es útil para
la búsqueda; la tercera parte de la lección trata sobre el número de iteraciones
en el algoritmo de Grover, o en otras palabras, el número de veces que se debe aplicar la operación de Grover, suponiendo que queremos
maximizar la probabilidad de que el algoritmo tenga éxito al encontrar lo que estamos buscando, mientras se minimiza su
costo; comenzaremos con el problema de búsqueda única, que es un caso especial en el que hay exactamente una solución a nuestro
problema de búsqueda, y luego consideraremos qué ocurre cuando hay múltiples soluciones; finalmente, concluiré la
lección con algunas observaciones breves sobre el algoritmo de Grover y sus generalizaciones; comencemos con el
problema computacional que abordaremos a lo largo de la lección; primero, como solemos hacer, vamos
a dejar que Sigma denote el alfabeto binario y usaremos esta notación a lo largo de toda la lección, así que no seguiré
recordándotelo; supongamos que tenemos una función f que asigna cadenas binarias de cierta longitud n al
alfabeto binario; nuestra suposición es que podemos evaluar esta función fácilmente, por
ejemplo, quizás tenemos un Boolean circuit para esta función cuyo tamaño es polinomial en n; ahora bien, esto no significa que sea
necesariamente una función simple en ningún sentido, ni que tengamos una comprensión particularmente buena de esta función; por ejemplo, quizás tenemos un
Boolean circuit bastante complicado y enrevesado para computar f, que nos permite evaluarla en diferentes cadenas de entrada, pero que no necesariamente tiene una
forma elegante diseñada para facilitarnos las cosas; nuestro objetivo es encontrar una solución, con lo cual nos referimos
a una cadena binaria de longitud n que hace que f evalúe a uno; en general, este es un problema computacional muy difícil,
o al menos sospechamos que lo es; en particular, si la entrada es de hecho la
descripción de un Boolean circuit para computar la función f, entonces este es un problema llamado NP-completo; una forma
de formalizar este problema es como un problema de consulta y, de hecho, para los propósitos de esta lección es razonable
pensar en este problema puramente en el contexto del modelo de consulta; pero cuando pensamos en dónde o cuándo
este problema puede surgir en la práctica, es más natural pensar en f como siendo computada por un Boolean circuit
como vimos en la lección seis, aunque podemos conectar estos dos puntos de vista a través de la construcción que realizamos para tomar un Boolean circuit y
convertirlo en un quantum circuit para implementar una operación de consulta o un query gate; en cualquier caso, conceptualmente hablando,
la entrada al problema es esta función f y buscamos una solución si es que existe, y si
no hay solución, es decir, si f resulta ser la función constante cero, entonces la salida correcta es reportar
que no hay soluciones; este es un problema de búsqueda no estructurada en el sentido de que no hay
nada especial en f que facilite encontrar una solución; no es como si estuviéramos buscando
en datos que ya han sido ordenados o cargados en alguna estructura de datos que facilite la búsqueda, y no hay ninguna promesa sobre la
función f que pueda ayudarnos; una forma de pensarlo es que es como buscar un número de teléfono específico
en una guía telefónica, a diferencia de buscar un nombre, lo cual es mucho más fácil suponiendo que los nombres estén
ordenados alfabéticamente; en términos prácticos, realmente no se trata de buscar en datos
que tendemos a organizar y almacenar de una manera que facilite la búsqueda; es más representativo de buscar una
solución a una ecuación complicada, por ejemplo, o quizás buscar la combinación que abre una
cerradura; como acotación, tiene sentido pensar en este problema en el contexto del modelo de consulta, independientemente de lo que pensemos
sobre la relevancia práctica de ese modelo; claro que no existen oráculos ni cajas negras en la vida real, pero hasta que
aprendamos lo contrario, los Boolean circuits complicados y misteriosos son algo así como cajas
negras; ahora pensemos en los algoritmos para resolver este problema de búsqueda no estructurada, y lo haremos
en el modelo de consulta solo por simplicidad; si tenemos un Boolean circuit para nuestra función en lugar de una caja negra,
podemos seguir ejecutando algoritmos de consulta en él, pero por supuesto no podemos descartar la posibilidad de que se descubra algún nuevo algoritmo
para este problema que no esté basado en hacer consultas, pero no nos preocuparemos por esa
posibilidad; primero, solo un poco de notación: el número total de cadenas de entrada a la función f es 2 elevado a
n minúscula, donde n minúscula es la longitud de las cadenas de entrada de f, y de aquí en adelante voy a dejar que N mayúscula sea este número, 2 elevado a
n minúscula; es bastante común que la gente use una letra mayúscula así para denotar dos elevado a la potencia de la minúscula
versión de esa letra vamos a hablar mucho del número N mayúscula así que esto va a ser
conveniente y ayudará a mantener las cosas un poco más ordenadas y de nuevo esta notación se aplica durante
toda la lección ahora, por supuesto, podemos resolver el problema de búsqueda de forma clásica simplemente
iterando por todas las posibles cadenas de n bits en el orden que elijamos, evaluando F en cada una de
ellas; si encontramos una solución en algún momento podemos detenernos, pero en el peor caso terminaremos evaluando F en cada una
de las cadenas de entrada, así que esto requiere n, es decir, N mayúscula
consultas; podríamos optar por medir el coste de este cálculo de otra manera, no solo en términos del número de consultas sino el número de consultas
representa el número de veces que tenemos que evaluar la función f, y es razonable esperar que las evaluaciones de f dominen el coste
de este cálculo; esto es de hecho lo mejor que podemos hacer con un algoritmo determinista
y de nuevo esto es en el contexto del modelo de consulta; si hemos consultado cada entrada
excepto una de ellas y F ha tomado el valor cero en todas ellas hasta ahora, ¿cómo podemos estar seguros de que la última
cadena no es la solución? Y la respuesta es que no podemos, así que sí necesitamos todas las n consultas en el peor
caso; también podríamos usar la aleatoriedad, que puede ofrecer algunas mejoras muy pequeñas, como reducir el
número esperado de consultas necesarias para encontrar una solución cuando existe una, o podríamos efectivamente intercambiar corrección
por una reducción en las consultas; pero como sea que lo analices, seguiremos necesitando un número de consultas que es lineal
en N; así que clásicamente hablando necesitamos un número lineal de consultas, es decir, lineal
en N mayúscula; el algoritmo de Grover es un algoritmo cuántico de búsqueda que lo hace mejor: requiere solo O grande de
la raíz cuadrada de n consultas; esas consultas ocurren en superposición, así que no es magia, pero
sí es una mejora significativa sobre lo que es posible clásicamente, y esto es lo que se entiende por una
ventaja cuadrática; ¿puede esta ventaja cuadrática de lo cuántico sobre lo clásico convertirse en una ventaja real en un sentido práctico?
Probablemente no pronto, pero en un futuro lejano, quién sabe; pero incluso si
el algoritmo de Grover nunca lleva a una ventaja práctica para la búsqueda, sigue siendo una parte importante de
los fundamentos de los algoritmos cuánticos que vale la pena entender; antes de pasar al propio algoritmo de Grover, necesitamos
hablar brevemente sobre los llamados gate de consulta de fase; muchos algoritmos cuánticos en el modelo de consulta se expresan naturalmente
usando gate de consulta de fase, y veremos que el algoritmo de Grover es un
ejemplo específico; empecemos con un repaso rápido de los gate de consulta ordinarios para una función f de
la forma de la que hemos estado hablando; el gate de consulta UF se define sobre estados de la base estándar como se muestra en la
pantalla, y para superposiciones de estados de la base estándar la acción está determinada por linealidad; y vale la pena recordar
que a partir de un circuit booleano para f, de hecho podemos construir un circuit para esta operación UF con un coste que es
lineal en el tamaño del circuit booleano; el gate de consulta de fase para f, por otro lado, que denotaremos por
el nombre ZF, opera de esta manera; en particular, este gate opera sobre
n qubit en lugar de n más uno qubit, y básicamente solo lleva automáticamente el valor de la función
a la fase en lugar de hacer XOR del valor de salida sobre un qubit adicional como tenemos para
UF; así que si pensamos en lo que ocurre cuando usamos phase Kickback en un gate UF
básicamente solo estamos implementando un gate ZF; necesitamos un estado menos y cuesta una
evaluación de UF; pero de hecho recuperamos el estado menos y podemos usarlo para el siguiente si queremos, o
podemos simplemente descartarlo; así que eso es lo que es un gate de consulta de fase; ahora bien, si simplemente
nos dan un gate de consulta de fase ZF y esta es la única forma en que tenemos acceso a la función f, entonces en realidad no podemos
recuperar un gate UF; pero si tenemos una versión controlada de ZF, entonces podemos
construir un gate UF, y te dejo ese como
ejercicio; además del gate de consulta de fase para la función f, también vamos a necesitar un gate de consulta de fase para la función
OR de n bits, es decir, la función que toma el valor cero cuando se le da la cadena de ceros y en caso contrario
toma el valor uno; y explícitamente la forma en que zor opera sobre los estados de la base estándar se muestra
aquí en la pantalla; este gate no tiene ninguna dependencia de la función f, así que no requiere
ninguna consulta; y una forma en que podemos construir un circuit cuántico que implementa esta operación es haciendo algo
similar a lo que hicimos para la función f, salvo que empezamos con un circuit booleano que calcula la función OR sobre
n bits; y ahora que tenemos estos gate, estamos listos para pasar a la siguiente
sección; ahora vamos a ver el algoritmo de Grover, empezando por una descripción del algoritmo; comenzamos inicializando
n qubit cada uno en el estado más, es decir, ponemos estos qubit en una superposición igual de todos
los strings binarios de longitud n; lo que vamos a hacer es efectivamente dirigir el estado de estos qubit
hacia una solución, así que es intuitivo que empecemos en este estado porque todavía no sabemos nada sobre la función f
en este punto; cada string tiene la misma probabilidad de ser una solución y eso se refleja en el hecho de que estos qubit están en una superposición igual de todos
los strings; y luego iteramos: aplicamos repetidamente la operación de Grover, que es realmente el núcleo del
algoritmo, y la describiré en un momento; aplicamos esta operación un total de T veces, donde T es algún entero no negativo,
pero este número no está especificado por el propio algoritmo; tenemos que elegir T de alguna manera, y en la siguiente
sección hablaremos sobre buenas elecciones para T; pero por ahora podemos pensar en este número de iteraciones T como
algo arbitrario; y finalmente medimos en la base estándar, y eso nos da un
candidato a solución; no hay garantía de que sea una solución, pero si elegimos T bien
la probabilidad de obtener una solución puede hacerse grande; y aquí está la operación de Grover
en sí, a la que hemos llamado G; es una composición de operaciones, todas ellas sobre N qubit, así que esta es una operación de N
qubit; primero tenemos un gate ZF, es decir, un gate de consulta de fase para la
función de entrada f, seguido de una capa de gate Hadamard, y luego tenemos zor, que es el gate de consulta de fase para la función
OR, y finalmente otra capa de gate Hadamard; así que vemos que una iteración en
el paso dos puede implementarse mediante un circuit con la forma mostrada aquí en la pantalla; aquí tenemos cuatro qubit, por cierto,
pero en general podemos tener cualquier número de qubit; algo clave a tener en cuenta aquí es que necesitamos una consulta de f para implementar G
necesitamos una consulta para implementar ZF y ninguna de las otras operaciones depende de F, así que no requieren consultas, entonces este número T que
representa el número de veces que aplicamos G en el paso dos también representa el número de consultas que
necesitamos. Aquí hay una forma típica en que podríamos usar el algoritmo de Grover, aunque ciertamente no es la única forma, como dije
antes. Lo primero que tenemos que hacer es elegir T, y eso lo veremos en la próxima sección.
Para cualquier T que elijamos, ejecutamos el algoritmo de Grover durante T iteraciones y obtenemos una solución candidata.
X. No hay garantía de que X sea realmente una solución, pero podemos hacer una consulta adicional para verificar. Si tenemos una solución, entonces podemos
dar esa solución y detenernos. De lo contrario, podemos intentarlo de nuevo, posiblemente con una elección diferente de T,
aunque no necesariamente, o podemos rendírnos y reportar que no hay soluciones. Como dije antes, esta
no es la única forma de usar el algoritmo, pero es una forma natural de aplicarlo al problema de búsqueda. A continuación veremos qué hace la operación de Grover
al estado de los N qubits sobre los que actúa. Pensemos en nuestros n qubits como
formando un único registro, al que llamaré Q, solo por darle un nombre. Recuerda que lo primero que hacemos en
el algoritmo de Grover es poner Q en una superposición uniforme de todas las cadenas de n bits, y lo hacemos aplicando gates Hadamard
a n qubits en el estado todo ceros. Luego iteramos la operación de Grover G y después
medimos. Va a ser útil dividir el conjunto de todas las cadenas de n bits en dos conjuntos: A cero y
A uno. A cero contiene todas las cadenas que hacen que F evalúe a cero, y A uno contiene todas las cadenas que hacen que F
evalúe a uno. Otra forma de decirlo es que A uno contiene todas las soluciones a nuestro problema de búsqueda,
mientras que A cero contiene todas las no-soluciones. Vamos a estar especialmente
interesados en dos estados cuánticos. Uno es la superposición uniforme sobre todas las no-soluciones, que es ket A cero, y el
otro es la superposición uniforme sobre todas las soluciones, que es ket A uno. Debo señalar que estas definiciones solo tienen
sentido cuando estos conjuntos son no vacíos, porque de lo contrario estaríamos sumando cero cosas y dividiendo entre cero. A medida que avancemos
en este análisis del algoritmo de Grover, iremos asumiendo eso. Podemos determinar fácilmente qué hace
el algoritmo de Grover cuando f es la función constante cero o la función constante uno, tratándolos como casos especiales, pero eso lo voy a dejar
para que lo hagas tú por tu cuenta. Como es de esperar, si toda cadena es una solución, efectivamente obtendremos una
solución al medir, y si no hay soluciones, no obtendremos ninguna, porque en ese caso no
hay ninguna. Pero para este análisis vamos a asumir que ambos conjuntos son no vacíos, de modo que estas
definiciones de los dos estados tengan sentido. Por cierto, esta es una notación bastante común:
siempre que tenemos un conjunto finito no vacío s, podemos escribir ket s para referirnos a la superposición uniforme sobre los
elementos de ese conjunto, igual que aquí. Así que recopilemos estas definiciones de esta forma y veamos cómo se conectan
al algoritmo de Grover. El primer paso del algoritmo de Grover es el paso de inicialización, que pone Q en una superposición uni forme
sobre todas las cadenas de n bits. Y para darle a este estado un nombre fácilmente reconocible, lo voy a llamar
ket u. U es la abreviatura de uniforme. Para el análisis es importante que primero notemos que
este estado uniforme ket u está contenido en el subespacio generado por los dos vectores ket A cero y ket
A uno. En particular, si tomamos la combinación lineal de estos dos estados que se muestra aquí en pantalla, obtendremos ket
u. Ahora bien, la clave de todo el análisis es el hecho de que el estado de Q permanece en
este subespacio bidimensional sin importar cuántas veces apliquemos la operación de Grover. Así que todo se va a reducir a
lo que ocurre en un subespacio bidimensional. Ahora veamos qué hace la operación de Grover y, en particular, qué hace
a los vectores del subespacio bidimensional generado por ket A cero y ket
A uno. Es útil imaginar que G se divide en dos partes: una parte es el gate ZF
y la otra parte es el gate Z cero, intercalado entre dos capas de gates Hadamard.
Aquí está la definición de ZF de antes, y a partir de esa definición es bastante directo ver que su
acción sobre nuestros dos estados —las superposiciones uniformes de no-soluciones y soluciones— consiste simplemente en colocar un signo menos
delante de ket A uno. Bueno, a ket A cero no le pasa nada, y eso es todo lo que realmente necesitamos saber
sobre ZF para este análisis. Para la segunda parte, que es
el gate Z cero intercalado entre dos capas de gates Hadamard, empecemos recordando cómo se define Z cero. Una forma de escribirlo
es como se muestra en pantalla. Esta es la misma expresión que antes, y otra forma de expresarlo usando la notación directa
es así. Puedes verificar esta expresión simplemente pensando en cómo actúa la operación del lado derecho
sobre los estados de la base estándar. En particular, no hace nada al estado todo ceros, y a cada
otro estado de la base estándar le aplica un signo menos, lo cual concuerda con la definición de Z
cero. Entonces, si intercalamos esta operación entre dos capas de gates Hadamard, obtenemos una expresión similar, excepto
que en lugar del estado de la base estándar todo ceros, ahora tenemos nuestra superposición uniforme ket u, y eso es porque H tensor
n transforma el estado de la base estándar ket cero a ket u, y además H tensor n es su propia transpuesta conjugada, así que funciona de manera
similar actuando desde la derecha sobre el bra en lugar del ket. Y ahora vamos a determinar
qué hace G a nuestros dos vectores A cero y A uno usando los hechos que acabamos de
observar. Empecemos con A cero. Primero, sustituyamos la expresión
que obtuvimos para el gate Z cero intercalado entre dos capas de gates Hadamard. A continuación, podemos usar el hecho de que ZF no hace nada
a ket A cero, así que podemos eliminar la operación ZF. Y ahora, usando la descripción
de ket u que tenemos aquí arriba, junto con el hecho de que ket A cero y ket A uno son vectores unitarios ortogonales, podemos calcular
el producto de este bra y este ket, y lo que obtenemos es la raíz cuadrada del número de no-soluciones
dividida por n. Podemos usar este resultado para evaluar lo que obtenemos y, al sustituir nuestra expresión para ket u y
simplificar, obtenemos el resultado final que se muestra aquí en pantalla. En particular, nota que este
vector está contenido en el subespacio bidimensional generado por ket A cero y ket A uno, como sugerí antes, y
además los coeficientes resultan ser números reales. Como siempre, verifica esto a tu
propio ritmo si decides hacerlo. Tiendo a ir rápido en estas cosas en los videos, con la
expectativa de que pausarás el video para pensarlo un poco si así lo decides. Así que limpiemos esto para poder
guardar el resultado final para más adelante. Y ahora haremos algo similar para el vector ket
En A1 podemos usar la misma expresión de G que antes y esta vez el gate ZF inyecta
un signo menos que aquí se refleja en el hecho de que hemos intercambiado los dos términos de la operación entre
paréntesis; luego procedemos de forma muy similar y el resultado final es parecido, salvo que los dos coeficientes
están intercambiados y ahora tenemos un signo menos delante de uno de ellos, que es simplemente como sale el álgebra, y de nuevo
puedes comprobar esto a tu propio ritmo. Fíjate que, una vez más, tenemos una combinación lineal real de nuestros dos vectores K a0 y
K A1. También limpiaremos éste y pondremos el resultado final junto al otro, y ahora podemos ver cómo G
actúa sobre el subespacio generado por nuestros dos vectores. Una forma de hacerlo es expresarlo en términos de la matriz 2x2 M que se
muestra aquí en pantalla. Y para dejar claro qué estamos haciendo: estamos asociando la primera fila y la primera
columna con K a0, y la segunda fila y columna con K A1. Hasta aquí en la serie, realmente
solo usamos matrices para describir cómo funcionan las operaciones sobre los estados de la base estándar. Pero es habitual usar matrices
para describir las acciones de las aplicaciones lineales sobre distintos conjuntos de vectores, no solo sobre los estados de la base estándar. Y aquí hablamos de lo que hace la operación G
a los vectores K a0 y K A1. Podemos decir más sobre lo que G hace a los vectores en el
span de K a0 y K A1 si examinamos más de cerca esta matriz M. Y en particular, lo que vamos a encontrar es
que M es una matriz de rotación, lo que significa que su acción sobre este espacio bidimensional puede describirse como una rotación por un
ángulo fijo. Hay un par de formas distintas de ver esto, y una es observar
que esta matriz M puede expresarse como el cuadrado de una matriz con aspecto algo más simple. Puede ser difícil de detectar si
solo miramos M por sí sola, pero no es algo que tengamos que descubrir por nuestra cuenta: solo tenemos que verificarlo, y podemos hacerlo simplemente
elevando al cuadrado la matriz de la derecha. Otra forma de escribir la matriz de la derecha, sin incluir el cuadrado, es
la que se muestra en pantalla, y esta es la forma típica de describir una rotación de un ángulo dado Theta como una
matriz. El ángulo preciso por el que rotamos resulta ser el arcoseno de la raíz cuadrada del número de
soluciones dividido entre n. Por cierto, como es la primera vez que lo vemos, cabe señalar que
este ángulo es muy importante: va a seguir apareciendo a medida que continuemos con este
análisis. El argumento del arcoseno es un número entre 0 y 1, y concretamente la forma en que
interpretamos el arcoseno aquí es que es el ángulo entre 0 y Pi/2 que nos da el argumento cuando tomamos
el seno. Esa es una forma de pensar en esta matriz que elevamos al cuadrado para obtener
M. Y como elevar al cuadrado la matriz equivale a aplicarla dos veces, vemos que M puede escribirse alternativamente como una
rotación no de un ángulo Theta sino de 2 * Theta, porque al elevar al cuadrado rotamos por un ángulo Theta
dos veces. Una forma distinta de verificar todo esto, por si resulta útil, es partir de esta expresión final de M
y usar las fórmulas del ángulo doble de trigonometría para obtener la expresión original de
M. Y esta es la expresión de M que describe la acción que G tiene sobre el subespacio generado por K a0 y K A1, que es la que
será más útil a partir de ahora. Volviendo ahora al propio algoritmo de Grover, tras el
paso de inicialización pero antes de realizar ninguna aplicación de G, el estado de nuestro registro Q de n qubit es K u, la
superposición uniforme sobre todas las cadenas de n bits. Y aquí tenemos la misma expresión de K u en términos de K a0 y
K A1 que antes. Pero ahora que hemos identificado este ángulo Theta, vemos que podríamos
escribir alternativamente K u como coseno Theta * K a0 más seno Theta * K
A1. Eso está claro para el coeficiente de K A1, y para el otro coeficiente solo tenemos que observar que el tamaño de a0 más
el tamaño de A1 es n, y luego podemos obtenerlo con un poco de trigonometría básica. Así que ese es el estado con el que
empezamos, y la primera vez que aplicamos G rotamos un ángulo de 2 * Theta, por lo que el ángulo total pasa a ser 3 *
Theta. Y si aplicamos G de nuevo, el ángulo aumenta a 5 Theta, porque hemos rotado efectivamente un
ángulo adicional de 2 Theta. Y así sucesivamente. Así que después de T aplicaciones de G podemos representar el
estado que obtenemos tal como se muestra en pantalla, donde el ángulo de nuestro estado es igual a 2T + 1 * Theta: son 2 * Theta
por cada aplicación de G, más un Theta adicional porque ese es el estado en que empezamos.
También podemos pensar en la acción de la operación de Grover en términos geométricos, y esto ayuda a arrojar luz sobre cómo
funciona y por qué su efecto es rotar el estado del registro Q. Esta es la idea principal: la operación de Grover
es una composición de las dos partes que ya hemos identificado. Una es ZF y la otra es Z o seno entre
dos capas de gates Hadamard. Estas dos partes son
reflexiones, y cuando componemos dos reflexiones obtenemos una rotación. Veamos cómo funciona esto con
más detalle. Primero centrémonos en ZF, y vamos a restringir nuestra atención al mismo
subespacio bidimensional del que hemos estado hablando, es decir, el que está generado por K a0 y K
A1. Como ya observamos, la acción de ZF sobre este espacio es bastante simple: no hace
nada a K a0 y pone un signo menos delante de K A1. Esto es una reflexión, y concretamente
es una reflexión respecto a la recta paralela a K a0, que llamaremos L1 solo para darle un
nombre. Para ver por qué es una reflexión, ayuda dibujar una figura. Aquí tenemos nuestros dos vectores K
a0 y K A1, que son vectores unitarios ortogonales, y podemos pensar en la pantalla como formada por todas las
combinaciones lineales reales de estos dos vectores. Así que el círculo representa todos los vectores unitarios para los que los coeficientes de
estos dos vectores son números reales. Aquí está la recta L1, que es paralela a K a0, y si consideramos algún
vector arbitrario s sobre este círculo, el efecto de aplicar ZF es reflejarlo respecto a esta recta, tal como se ilustra en la
pantalla, simplemente porque no hacemos nada a K a0 y ponemos un signo menos delante de K
A1. En el caso especial en que s es K a0, por ejemplo, no ocurre nada cuando realizamos esta reflexión. Y cuando s es
K A1, la reflexión nos lleva hasta el K A1 negativo, lo que es coherente con la acción de ZF. Así que ZF es una
reflexión que puede visualizarse como hemos visto aquí. La segunda parte de G, que es Z o
sándwich entre dos capas de gates Hadamard, puede expresarse como 2 * K u bra menos la matriz identidad, como
ya vimos, y de nuevo esto es una reflexión, esta vez respecto a la recta L2 paralela a K u en lugar de K
a0. Podemos visualizar esta operación de forma similar a ZF. Aquí está el vector K
hipotéticamente, así que esta es la recta L2 paralela a K y, una vez más, la acción sobre un vector arbitrario s es reflejarlo
en relación a la línea que es L2 en este caso
y finalmente, como mencioné antes, cada vez que componemos dos reflexiones obtenemos una rotación, y específicamente es
una rotación del doble del ángulo entre las líneas de reflexión, así que vamos a dibujar algo similar
a lo que teníamos antes: aquí están las líneas de reflexión que forman el ángulo Theta entre
ellas, y si tomamos algún vector arbitrario s reflejado alrededor de la primera línea L1 y
luego reflejado sobre la segunda línea L2, el efecto neto será rotar el vector s un ángulo del doble de Theta
y esto es algo que se cumple en general, y puedes probarlo con algunos ejemplos adicionales por tu cuenta para ver que así es efectivamente como funciona
de todas formas, con suerte esto te ayuda a tener algo de intuición sobre por qué la operación de Grover tiene el efecto de rotar
vectores. A continuación veremos el tema de elegir el número de iteraciones T en el algoritmo de Grover
empecemos pensando en cómo el análisis que hemos visto hasta ahora, que revela lo que hace la operación de Grover,
cuando la aplicamos repetidamente a la superposición uniforme, se relaciona con la tarea que esperamos resolver, que es encontrar una solución a nuestro problema de búsqueda
o en otras palabras, cualquier cadena contenida en el conjunto A1. En resumen, básicamente vamos a establecer
un objetivo y luego determinar cuántas veces aplicar la operación de Grover para acercarnos a ese
objetivo. Primero imaginemos que tenemos cualquier estado que sea una combinación lineal de nuestros dos vectores K a0 y K
A1. Si realizamos una medición en la base estándar sobre este estado, vamos a obtener un resultado en el conjunto A1, que es
el conjunto de soluciones a nuestro problema de búsqueda, con una probabilidad igual al valor absoluto al cuadrado de cualquier coeficiente que tengamos para K A1, y para el
vector que se muestra en la pantalla, ese coeficiente es beta. Esto es intuitivo: si fuéramos a medir el estado K a0
obtendríamos una no-solución aleatoria, y si medimos K A1 obtendríamos una solución aleatoria. Entonces si medimos este estado
aquí mismo, obtendremos una no-solución aleatoria con probabilidad igual al valor absoluto de Alpha al cuadrado, y una solución aleatoria
con probabilidad igual al valor absoluto de beta al cuadrado. Pero también podemos tomarnos un momento para calcularlo: aquí está el estado escrito
de forma que podamos ver cuáles son las entradas de este vector para los estados de la base estándar. Entonces si medimos, estas son las
probabilidades de obtener cada posible resultado, y para obtener la probabilidad de obtener una solución sumamos las
probabilidades de todas las posibles soluciones, lo que nos da el valor absoluto de beta al cuadrado, como
era de esperar. Ahora ya hemos analizado lo que ocurre cuando ejecutamos el algoritmo de Grover durante T iteraciones: obtenemos el estado que se
muestra aquí en la pantalla. Entonces, como el coeficiente de K A1 es el seno
de 2T + 1 multiplicado por Theta, donde nuevamente aquí está este ángulo muy importante Theta,
veremos una solución con probabilidad sen²(2T + 1) multiplicado por
Theta. Nos gustaría hacer esa probabilidad grande, idealmente lo más cercana a uno posible. Entonces mientras rotamos el vector de estado
iterando G, pensaremos en K A1 como el estado objetivo e intentaremos
elegir T de forma que terminemos cerca de este estado. Y mientras hacemos esto, conviene tener en mente que también nos gustaría
minimizar T, porque ese es el número de consultas que necesitamos hacer. Entonces si queremos que esta
probabilidad sea cercana a uno y minimizar T, tiene sentido intentar que el ángulo de nuestro vector de estado sea cercano a Pi/2, porque
ese es el ángulo más pequeño que hace grande el cuadrado del seno, por lo que básicamente es nuestra primera oportunidad de hacer la probabilidad grande mientras
rotamos el vector de estado. Ahora no necesariamente podemos alcanzar exactamente este ángulo pi entre 2, porque T tiene que
ser un entero. Pero si lo pensamos de forma aproximada y despejamos T como si fuera una desigualdad, vemos que idealmente
elegir T igual a pi entre 4 multiplicado por Theta menos 1/2 tiene
sentido. Pero claro, T debe ser un entero no negativo, por lo que lo que haremos es
tomar el entero más cercano a lo que imaginamos como este valor ideal, que es el piso de pi dividido entre 4 multiplicado por
Theta. Tomar el piso, por cierto, simplemente significa que descartamos cualquier parte fraccionaria; en otras palabras, es el entero más grande
que es menor o igual a lo que sea que estemos tomando el piso. Según esta expresión, si el
valor ideal resulta estar a mitad de camino entre dos enteros, redondearemos hacia arriba, pero eso no importará en absoluto para
los propósitos de esta lección. Entonces, de aquí en adelante vamos a centrarnos en esta elección particular de
T. Pero hay otra consideración importante que debemos tener en cuenta, que es que esta especificación de T depende
de cuántas soluciones hay, porque el ángulo Theta depende del número de
soluciones. De aquí en adelante voy a usar la letra s para referirme al número de soluciones, o en otras palabras, el tamaño del
conjunto A1, simplemente por comodidad. De todas formas, el punto es que nuestra
expresión para T, el valor que estamos suponiendo debería ser bueno, depende de Theta, y Theta depende de S, que es
el tamaño del conjunto A1. Esto no es un problema si sabemos de antemano cuántas soluciones hay, pero
si no sabemos cuántas soluciones hay de antemano, no sabemos cuál es Theta, así que no podemos elegir T de esta forma
y tendremos que hacer algo diferente. Volveré a la situación en que no conocemos s un poco más adelante, pero
empecemos por la situación en que sí sabemos cuántas soluciones hay, comenzando con la búsqueda única,
donde se garantiza que hay una única solución que estamos buscando
Mencioné el problema de búsqueda única como ejemplo de un problema de consulta en la lección
cinco. La entrada es una función f de n bits a un bit; hay una cadena única de n bits
que hace que F evalúe a uno, y el objetivo es devolver esa cadena. Entonces
esto es equivalente al problema de búsqueda no estructurada del que hemos estado hablando, pero con la promesa de que hay exactamente una solución. Y de hecho esta es
la única versión del problema de búsqueda que Lov Grover consideró en su artículo original de 1996, que introdujo el algoritmo de Grover.
Para la búsqueda única, tenemos que s es igual a 1, y por lo tanto este ángulo importante Theta es igual al arcoseno
de la raíz cuadrada de 1/N. Cuando N es grande, este valor es aproximadamente la raíz cuadrada de 1/N, y
esto se debe a que para ángulos cada vez más pequeños, la función seno empieza a parecerse cada vez más a la función identidad.
Si sustituimos esa aproximación en nuestra selección de T, vemos que T es aproximadamente el piso
de pi entre 4 multiplicado por la raíz cuadrada de N. Eso es bueno porque vamos por buen camino para usar O grande de la raíz cuadrada de N
consultas, aunque en este punto aún no hemos examinado exactamente qué tan bien funciona el algoritmo.
Veamos un ejemplo donde N mayúscula es 128, que es 2^7, así que
nuestra función f va de siete bits a un bit, y asumimos que hay una solución única. Pero para determinar cómo
el algoritmo funciona, realmente solo necesitamos ocuparnos del ángulo Theta, que podemos calcular, y es
aproximadamente 0,0885 radianes, lo que equivale a poco más de 5°, y si introducimos ese valor en nuestra
expresión para T, obtenemos ocho. Así que estamos pensando en lo que ocurre cuando buscamos una solución única entre 128
posibilidades usando ocho consultas. Podemos hacer un dibujo para ilustrar cómo cambia el estado con
el tiempo a medida que realizamos iteraciones de la operación de Grover. Como antes, tenemos los estados ket
a0 y ket A1, y en este caso particular, es decir, búsqueda única, tenemos que ket A1 es en realidad el estado de la base estándar
correspondiente a la solución única, sea cual sea. Bueno, ket a0 es la superposición uniforme sobre todos los
strings excepto la solución única. Aquí está la superposición uniforme sobre todos los strings, que
podemos escribir como coseno Theta ket a0 más seno Theta ket A1, y tiene sentido que ket a0
y ket U estén cerca en este caso, porque como acabamos de observar un momento atrás, ket a0 es
casi la superposición uniforme sobre todos los strings; solo falta un string, que es la solución única. Aplicar G de nuevo rota un
2 Theta adicional, así que aquí es donde estamos después de dos iteraciones. Aquí hay tres, 4, 5, 6, 7 y 8.
Y ahora vemos que estamos bastante cerca de ket A1, así que si nos detenemos y medimos en este punto, es muy probable que obtengamos
la solución única. De hecho, en este caso solo hay alrededor de medio punto porcentual de probabilidad de no obtener la solución única.
Por otro lado, si continuáramos aplicando la operación de Grover más de las ocho veces recomendadas,
la probabilidad de obtener una solución bajaría de nuevo, y con el tiempo oscilaría a medida que el estado va girando
por el círculo. Así que es importante que detengamos las iteraciones en el momento correcto si queremos tener éxito con alta
probabilidad. Pensemos en la probabilidad de que nuestra elección de T revele la solución única de forma más general para distintos valores de
n. Escribiremos pn1 para denotar la probabilidad de que el algoritmo de Grover tenga éxito al encontrar una solución única
para cada valor posible de n. El uno significa una solución, y extenderemos esta notación a otros números de soluciones
en breve. Aquí hay una tabla de estas probabilidades para pequeñas potencias de dos. Empieza con n igual a 2 y la
probabilidad es 1/2, lo que no está muy bien, pero luego para n igual a 4 la probabilidad es exactamente uno, así que en realidad funciona
perfectamente en este caso. Es un gran ejercicio, por cierto, ir explícitamente a través de cómo funcionan estos dos casos.
Particularmente el caso en que n es igual a cuatro. En ese caso, estamos buscando una solución entre cuatro posibilidades.
Solo necesitamos una sola consulta y funciona perfectamente. A medida que n crece, sí vemos algunas fluctuaciones; las probabilidades suben
y bajan un poco, pero parecen acercarse a uno, y de hecho es así. Se puede demostrar
analíticamente que la probabilidad es siempre al menos 1 - 1/n. Así que eso está bien.
El algoritmo no es perfecto; no tenemos garantizada una solución, pero es bastante probable, especialmente para valores grandes
de n, así como por la anomalía muy interesante que ocurre cuando n es igual a 4.
También debo señalar que siempre podemos ejecutar todo el algoritmo, incluyendo las mediciones, tantas veces como queramos, y si alguna de las ejecuciones
tiene éxito, obtendremos una solución. Así que si estas probabilidades no son suficientemente buenas, podemos mejorarlas fácilmente con solo ejecutar
el algoritmo de nuevo. De hecho, incluso si todas estas probabilidades fueran iguales a 1/2, por ejemplo, seguiríamos teniendo un
algoritmo de búsqueda útil. Ahora veamos qué ocurre cuando hay múltiples
soluciones. Comenzaremos con un ejemplo similar al anterior. De nuevo, n es igual a 128, pero esta vez el
número de soluciones s es cuatro en lugar de 1. De nuevo, podemos calcular Theta y T, y
obtenemos que Theta es aproximadamente 0,1777, o un poco más de 10°, y T es
cuatro esta vez. Así que el ángulo es aproximadamente el doble del valor del ejemplo anterior y T es la mitad de lo que
era. Podemos hacer un dibujo como antes. Aquí es donde
empezamos; aquí hay una iteración, dos, tres y cuatro. Esta vez estamos muy cerca de ket
A1, y la probabilidad de obtener una solución esta vez resulta ser mayor que
99,9%. Pero si no lo supiéramos mejor y creyéramos que solo hay una solución, tomaríamos T igual a 8, como
antes; rotaríamos casi completamente hasta llegar a ket a0 negativo, y eso llevaría a una probabilidad de
éxito muy pequeña. Así que ese es otro ejemplo que muestra que hay buenas elecciones de T y malas elecciones de T, y aquí vemos
que una buena elección para s igual a 1 resulta ser una pésima elección para s igual a 4. Pero suponiendo que sí conocemos s de
antemano y elegimos T según nuestra especificación, resulta que el algoritmo de Grover encontrará una solución
con probabilidad al menos 1 - s sobre n, y muchas veces será mucho mayor que eso. También es al menos s sobre n, pero
eso es en realidad mucho menos interesante. Lo más interesante es que a medida que la fracción s sobre n se hace pequeña, la cota
sobre la probabilidad de éxito se acerca cada vez más a uno. Ahora bien, como ya he señalado varias
veces, el número T representa no solo el número de iteraciones de la operación de Grover que realizamos, sino también el número
de consultas que hacemos. Entonces, ¿de qué depende este número con respecto a s y
n? Primero, partamos del hecho de que el arcoseno de x es siempre al menos x, siempre que x esté entre 0 y 1.
Eso es bastante fácil de demostrar si conoces la serie de Taylor para la función arcoseno, pero hay otras formas de razonarlo, y simplemente
lo tomaremos como dado porque es verdad. Eso significa que Theta es al menos la raíz cuadrada de s sobre
n, y en consecuencia T es como máximo π sobre 4 por la raíz cuadrada de n sobre
s. Así que eso es en realidad incluso mejor que O grande de raíz de n. Cuanto mayor sea s en
comparación con n, menos consultas necesitamos hacer, y en cierto modo no es sorprendente que aparezca esta fracción
así, dado que su recíproco define Theta y, al final del día, Theta es realmente lo único que importa para
este análisis. Como acabamos de ver, el algoritmo de Grover funciona bastante bien cuando sabemos
de antemano cuántas soluciones hay. Pero ¿qué pasa si no sabemos cuántas soluciones hay?
Hay un enfoque bastante simple, que consiste en elegir el número de iteraciones
aleatoriamente. Y específicamente, elegir T de forma uniforme y aleatoria entre uno y el piso de π sobre 4 por raíz de n resulta ser
una buena forma de hacerlo. El extremo superior de este rango es aproximadamente el número de consultas que elegiríamos para la búsqueda única, y en realidad
es exactamente el número correcto en la mayoría de los casos. Esto es cuando el ángulo Theta es tan pequeño como puede ser, excluyendo
el caso trivial en que no hay ninguna solución. La idea aquí es que en lugar de apuntar cuidadosamente nuestro vector de estado a
ket A1, como hicimos cuando sabíamos cuántas soluciones había, básicamente estamos rotando por un ángulo aleatorio, como si estuviéramos
simplemente dándole al vector de estado un giro aleatorio; si resulta que hay una sola solución, nuestro giro aleatorio podría empujar
el vector de estado cerca de KA1, pero también podría quedarse a mitad de camino; y si resulta que hay muchas soluciones, entonces
nuestro giro aleatorio podría potencialmente enviar el vector de estado alrededor del círculo múltiples veces, así que no esperamos que esto revele
una solución con una probabilidad cercana a uno, pero la probabilidad de que esto lleve a una solución, si es que hay alguna, resulta ser
bastante buena; siempre es al menos del 40%. De hecho, eso no es obvio, pero es el
caso. Desde luego no es sorprendente, porque un ángulo verdaderamente aleatorio tendría un 50% de probabilidad de encontrar una
solución de todas formas. El 40% no está nada mal, y recuerda que siempre podemos aumentar la probabilidad de encontrar una solución
repitiendo el proceso y eligiendo T de forma independiente cada vez. Al hacer esto, las probabilidades de no
encontrar una solución cuando existe disminuyen exponencialmente con el número de repeticiones. Así que si queremos un 99%
de probabilidad de encontrar una solución, lo que podemos hacer es ejecutar este enfoque simple 10 veces, de nuevo con T elegida de forma independiente cada
vez. Naturalmente, si no encontramos una solución, declaramos que no hay soluciones. Si no existen soluciones,
no encontraremos ninguna, y en ese caso siempre daremos la respuesta correcta: no hay soluciones. Si hay soluciones,
podríamos no encontrar ninguna y declarar incorrectamente que no hay soluciones, pero la probabilidad de que eso ocurra puede hacerse muy pequeña.
También tenemos, como mencioné hace unos momentos, que esto requiere un número de consultas o evaluaciones de f del orden Big O de la raíz de
n. Así que usando el algoritmo de Grover podemos resolver el problema de búsqueda con alta probabilidad con Big O de la raíz de n
consultas incluso si no sabemos de antemano cuántas soluciones hay. También existe un enfoque más sofisticado
que puede reducir el número de consultas a medida que aumenta el número de soluciones. No lo voy a describir en
detalle, sino que me centraré en la idea principal. Empezamos con T mayúscula igual
a uno. Luego ejecutamos el algoritmo de Grover con un número aleatorio de iteraciones, pero donde el límite superior es T, así que la primera
vez que llegamos al paso dos vamos a ejecutar el algoritmo de Grover con una iteración, pero T va a ir
creciendo. Si encontramos una solución, la devolvemos y paramos; y si no encontramos una solución, hacemos T
más grande y lo intentamos de nuevo, y en algún momento antes de que T se vuelva demasiado grande terminaremos el proceso y
declararemos que no hay soluciones. Es la misma idea básica que en el enfoque simple, donde le damos al
vector de estado giros aleatorios esencialmente, pero aquí empezamos con giros más ligeros primero, cuando T es
pequeño, por si acaso hay muchas soluciones. De esta manera no malgastamos consultas haciendo que el estado dé vueltas
y más vueltas al círculo girando demasiado fuerte; pero si no funciona, es decir, si no encontramos una solución, lo intentamos de nuevo
pero giramos un poco más fuerte, o potencialmente un poco más fuerte. Para que esto funcione, la tasa de
incremento de T tiene que elegirse cuidadosamente, y una forma de hacerlo es reemplazar T por el techo de 5/4 veces T.
Así que T se incrementa exponencialmente, e intuitivamente podemos pensarlo como girar un 25% más fuerte cada
vez. Es importante para el análisis que T aumente exponencialmente de esta manera. ¿Por qué 5/4?, te podrías preguntar. Bueno, es
simplemente un número que funciona, y de hecho hay un rango de valores que funcionan, pero dos no funciona, por ejemplo: doblar T
cada vez es un incremento demasiado rápido para aprovechar plenamente los beneficios de los giros más ligeros. En cualquier caso, el objetivo de este método más
sofisticado es que da el mismo límite asintótico en el número de consultas que necesitamos, como antes:
Big O de la raíz cuadrada de n/s, pero no necesitamos saber de antemano cuántas soluciones hay. Y por cierto,
podemos detener este proceso cuando T llegue a la raíz de n, así que si no hay soluciones llegaremos a esa conclusión después de Big O
de raíz de n consultas. Y así es como podemos elegir el número de iteraciones en el algoritmo de Grover. Para concluir la lección,
haré solo unos breves comentarios sobre el algoritmo de Grover. Primero, dentro del modelo de consultas,
el algoritmo de Grover es asintóticamente óptimo. Lo que eso significa es que no es posible desarrollar un
algoritmo de consultas para resolver el problema de búsqueda, ni siquiera el problema de búsqueda única específicamente, que utilice asintótica
mente menos de Big O de raíz de n consultas en el peor caso. Eso es algo que se puede demostrar rigurosamente,
y de hecho hay múltiples demostraciones conocidas de este hecho. Curiosamente, esto se sabía incluso
antes de que se descubriera el algoritmo de Grover. El algoritmo de Grover igualó la cota inferior ya conocida sobre el número de
consultas requeridas. De vez en cuando la gente propone enfoques que cree que son asintótica
mente superiores al algoritmo de Grover, pero siempre hay un error o una suposición sobre la función f y
cómo se puede acceder a ella, u otro problema que hace que la afirmación sea incorrecta. Si se trabaja correctamente
dentro del modelo de consultas, no se puede superar al algoritmo de Grover para la búsqueda no estructurada. Segundo, el algoritmo de Grover es
bastante ampliamente aplicable, en el sentido de que la aceleración de raíz cuadrada que ofrece el algoritmo de Grover para el problema de búsqueda no estructurada puede
obtenerse en una variedad de contextos diferentes. Por ejemplo, a veces es posible usar el algoritmo de Grover
sobre otro algoritmo para obtener una mejora cuadrática más allá del rendimiento de ese algoritmo. El algoritmo de Grover también se usa
con mucha frecuencia como subrutina dentro de otros algoritmos cuánticos. Como un ejemplo sencillo,
podemos usar el algoritmo de Grover para obtener una ventaja cuadrática sobre los algoritmos clásicos para el problema del mínimo que mencioné en
la lección cinco. Y por último, la técnica usada en el algoritmo de Grover, donde tenemos dos
reflexiones que se componen e iteran para rotar un vector de estado cuántico, puede generalizarse de una manera bastante
importante. Un ejemplo es una técnica conocida como amplificación de amplitud, donde un proceso
que generaliza el algoritmo de Grover puede aplicarse a otro algoritmo cuántico para potenciar su probabilidad de éxito cuadráticamente más rápido de lo que
sería posible clásicamente. Esa técnica tiene amplias aplicaciones en los algoritmos cuánticos. Así que puede ser cierto que
el algoritmo de Grover probablemente no conduzca a una Ventaja Cuántica práctica en un futuro próximo, si es que alguna vez lo hace, pero el algoritmo de Grover es
sin duda un algoritmo cuántico fundamentalmente importante y ampliamente aplicable, y es representativo de una técnica más general que tiene muchos
usos. Y eso es todo para esta lección y para esta unidad de la serie, que ha tratado sobre los algoritmos
cuánticos. Discutimos el modelo de consultas y cómo podemos conectarlo a un modelo de computación más estándar, junto con
algunos otros conceptos fundamentales sobre cómo podemos medir el coste computacional. Luego cubrimos la estimación de fase,
la factorización y finalmente el algoritmo de Grover. Como ya he sugerido,
hay mucho más que aprender sobre los algoritmos cuánticos, pero en esta serie pasaremos a un tema diferente en la próxima unidad. En concreto, echaremos un
vistazo a la formulación general de la información cuántica, donde los estados cuánticos se representan mediante matrices de un cierto
tipo conocidas como matrices de densidad. Como veremos, esta formulación resulta ser muy útil e incluso
esencial para entender algunos aspectos de la información cuántica, y además resulta ser bastante hermosa desde un punto de
vista matemático. Así que espero que te unas a mí en la unidad tres, y hasta
entonces adiós.